hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake and today we're
actually sitting down at the Silicon
Valley robotics Regional for FIRST
Robotics and we're sitting down with
team 31:32 thunder down under' with Jay
and Sarah Highway hello thank you for
coming and doing a little conversation
while we're all here this is good all
right so you guys won the Chairman's
Award at Worlds last year and
championships so that requires a team to
basically be the best team in the world
and in order to win that award which is
amazing and you have set up such in so
first robotics inspires young people
from the ages of six and cell 18
to design an engineer robust complete
objectives on playing fields but also to
do things like make business plans build
teamwork leverage things like emotional
intelligence flow people on the team it
really builds a great foundation for
moving forward into the world and so
that's how many kids is like 500,000
kids across the world in Australia for
FRC 600 teams it's over 3,000 oh is it
4,000 yes yeah 600 teams across the
globe there's about four thousand four
thousand these are high level
competition teams because the
competition fields for this higher level
like FIRST Robotics Competition is
somewhere around the size of probably
like half a basketball court basically
in size so the robots are what what is
it is it like three three feet by three
feet or as though it's about two feet by
four feet two feet by four feet okay and
so then so then you guys ended up do so
let's let's talk about kind of like
you're from Australia the teams from
Sydney well sort of we're actually not
from Australia is you're probably
Toolbar axons we're both American who've
lived there for nearly a decade so the
way kind of all got started was actually
when I was negative four months old so
inside mom first was founded in New
Hampshire in the United States which is
where I was born and my mom actually was
mentoring one of the first team so it
was only about five years into the whole
FIRST Robotics program and my mom's
mentoring this team she's really
pregnant and she had a great time so
fast forward about eight years when I
was old enough to actually get involved
and do FIRST LEGO League we started
there in New Hampshire and then when I
was in my sophomore year of high school
we moved from New Hampshire to Australia
and my one requirement for moving was
that we had to have a FIRST Robotics
Competition team for me to join I've
been doing it for two years absolutely
fell in love with the program and so at
that point my parents said sure first
was at the time was in about 50
countries but what they didn't realize
is that meant that the lower-level
program was in 50 countries yeah now
hiring a little program was in about
four and there were no teams in
Australia in fact the closest team was a
close very close it was only eight hours
via plane to Honolulu Hawaii come on and
we decided that Pauline wasn't gonna
work out so well so my parents being the
incredible people that they are decided
to found the team they got mermaid got a
first name Macquarie uni on board as one
our sponsor that's where we actually set
up the team they've gone on PA systems
and all team and we raised enough money
and we not only have the team we also
took them back to New Hampshire for our
first competition because obviously
there was really no that's the only team
when we got there there were about 20
FLL teams in the entire country that was
it for fur so the lower level only 20
teams there today we have nearly a
thousand teams
the country and it's growing like crazy
that was 10 years of involvement good
night yeah okay that's huge that's a
massive increase and how many of the
higher-level FIRST Robotics Competition
teams are there there's 50 to 52 from
zero yes whoa you have your own regional
now oh you have two one in Sydney
where's the other one still in Sydney
the both are in Sydney bunch said from
like week one week six I'm like that
actually they're both in week one this
year it was a one was at the start of
the week when once at the end of the
week which proves for me two days in
between the year before we did them
totally back-to-back so it was three
days for the first one in three days for
the second one six days straight three
I'm just insane competition this year
were look at the venue a little bit
longer but not that much longer so we
had the two day break which was very
much pinging during the sleep ins this
is amazing last about ten years or so
has been crazy growth for for their team
and for the country and that's a lot of
things to you know your mom being a
mentor falling in love with it and you
guys felt both falling in love with it
so so you want chairman's and one of the
one of the reasons why you want it was
because of the compass alliance you
would say then all the different
programs that you've put together
yessir probably the comments I
especially found that since we won but
there's yes
if anything speeding up on me we really
took winning the terms where does an
opportunity to do more and that's really
one of the reasons why we wanted to add
it was because we're in Australia there
are a lot of disadvantages to that and
we wanted to use the what advantages we
could get from the Chairman's Award to
fuel whatever we wanted to do afterwards
like the couple slams so the compass
Alliance as a consortium well it started
off as a consortium of ten it has to be
back up what do you think led you to win
chairman said first you don't call they
need it going um we do a lot of programs
and I think it's a mix of all of them
one of our biggest strengths is being
international as much as I said before
that is a disadvantage
it's also a very big advantage because
we we have so many connections to all
these other nations that America doesn't
really have because America is so big
and there's so many people in America
and you can just do things uh video
inside of America but we need to we
needed to reach out a lot and so one of
the programs that we have is mentors
Without Borders and that that is a
program for other teams where we send
our mentors to other teams and we help
them to get started or if they're
already a team we help them to get their
robot going and we send them to other
countries like we've sent people to pull
in through some people that China and
it's a really cool experience yeah in
fact all the teams that's here 4091 team
draft they were the first team in the
dominican republic we sent our meet
mentor to
the rookie season for the first week of
build season in total our team has
traveled enough to circle the globe ten
times so we just go everywhere but I
think it's bigger than just the mentors
about four as well so one of the things
that that I just said when we won was
that this team has changed our paradigm
and I think that goes really to the
heart of our team our team mission
statement is stem for everyone
everywhere and we take that incredibly
seriously and bringing first to not just
the schools that can afford it but
bringing it really the schools that
can't afford it or than anything else
and help empower those young kids to
find staff absolutely so we started a
program where we take it into the most
rural and remote towns you can imagine
we have a first team in a town of 120
people and we actually went there the
first year that we had the program that
does this and there is one high school
with kids it is supposed to be from K to
12 but they have kids in your five your
10 and your 12 couple the kids they
found the kids I know and then they came
to the regional that year and they
competed and it was really cool for them
and for us to see how yeah cool women
what do you think that tagline for me oh
I can't remember exactly who at Point
well yeah like Fort Meade in kind of two
ways so from the very beginning of our
team or a team mission statement was
them for it started off the stem for
everyone and this one year we were
working on our Chairman's mission we
were really struggling with how to
synthesize everything we had told the
judges and we were sitting there and
sitting there and just closing our eyes
and listening to the kids do this
presentation and do a presentation for
it and I'm just thinking about
everything we had done and all of a
sudden it just came just out of the blue
it's the words flew out almost stem for
everyone everywhere that's 100 per
second
and it from that point and time onward
that just became everything and that was
probably about five years ago at this
point and that just between the driving
force it really I mean it had always
been there but then all of a sudden it
just became so clear and so concise and
everyone everywhere was what we became
about and it became every handout every
speech every anything our team did had
everyone everywhere and I think one of
the coolest moments for us was about
three years into this everyone
everywhere a journey that we took the
founder of the program at championship
stood up on stage and he said first is
about going to everyone everywhere and
our whole team goes Bravo and do I think
that we put those words in his mouth
absolutely not but do you think it was
you know we were changing the way first
looked at it and the way other first
team looked at it that it wasn't just
for the rich all-boys private school all
of a sudden it was for the towns of 120
you was for the girl to have programs
for women it was for you know going to
alum in different countries and starting
FRC there it was about everyone and
that's how we're gonna make a real
difference in the world not just yeah
rich all-boys schools yes and you have
met adventures Without Borders and
you're going to the UM you have an
all-girls program you're now going into
more rural cities and bringing there you
have been for a while alright so we did
that first chunk which was about your
journey and now we're talking about
let's talk about the compass Alliance
this is fascinating this has come into
existence about the last two years or
the year year yeah okay six months six
months so it's basically the best teams
you you inspire the other teams to work
with you the other best teams that have
also won a Chairman's Award at camps
well that 971 has in 254 know they've
won the robot being the championships
before none of the team
working with have warmed the Chairman's
water championships there couple look at
it knows who happened
no well 254 have 0 min the compass
Alliance up oh they're not they're one
of the founding teams so they don't want
founding cubes are 10 founding teams but
then we also have Alliance partners for
250 fortune alliance partner but they're
not actually founding number the only
founding members here and i-71 ourselves
okay at night someone has one share was
haven't they know they have a regional
chairman our championship I'll be
customized the high rollers that won the
year before you yes okay all right
ninety eight nine eight seven yeah okay
all right so the compass Alliance the
two founding members are here you and
nine seven one yeah and so the there's a
bunch of different things that you do
here there's this two 24/7 call around
around the clock anyone from around the
world can call in and if you're you know
sleeping in the US someone in Australia
will pick up the phone if you're
sleeping in Australia someone in the US
will pick up the phone or in Europe or
in Asia and so that's amazing to pick up
and help you have this massive list of
of all the ways that of people people
getting started with first can can
leverage the materials that you've put
together to best understand how to
design an engineer robots
there's the XO there's accessibility for
within city if you need a field or if
you need something to help out you can
really quickly get in touch you can
definitely explain it better but I love
this country this is what I've been
talking about for so long first can put
together materials like this resource
like this you know that's the real
creative genius that comes from young
kids into this from this program yeah
it's been an amazing thing to be a part
of working with other nine teams like
the teams we currently have dreamed of
working with you even two years ago and
to come together on this project and
it's it was really a community within
than ten teams especially the founding
teams and just this notion of we want to
come together to do what we can to make
the community better and the way we came
up with that is this one-stop shop
because there's so many resources there
are too many resources and as a younger
team you don't know where to turn
yes you don't know what's good what's
bad what's indifferent and so we wanted
to create one place where they're
collated they're easy to find there's
their index they're searchable like you
can just get what you need very quickly
but then also you know if those
resources aren't enough you can just
live chat with some and break that in
there and they will respond immediately
right if you need a little more help
than just that that chat one-off we can
get you what we call a tag team of a
virtual mentor team if you need a
machine shop or field in your area we've
got a list of ones that are open and
available with contact information and
so as we pulled in more TV like this is
for you have ones available in Turkey if
one's available in China that you they
they told you that these are the
locations and you put them in - yeah and
as this story coming out and it
immediately took off within community
which was amazing we had two teams
afford a team in Turkey and the team in
Mexico and so now it's actually
available in three languages and these
teams maintain it in their language so
anytime you put up a new resource they
immediately translate it and I get an
email the next day by the way the
resource is now up in Spanish it's like
oh cool we have special resources now so
and the all of the resources translated
into another language not all of them
yet we're working on it but as we get
more they're getting there and I mention
the songs I look at a hundred percent
translation in those three languages
spanish i know spanish turkeys and
which obviously we're working on adding
Mandarin and probably Hebrew this the
sites in six months is going to the
point that our infrastructure can't
really support it um so we're gonna have
to like one domain of what we're using
Wix for something quick and maritime
just to throw something together to see
how this one you build it from scratch
we're gonna have to and so now we're
looking for web developers but I think
the coolest thing was gonna be started
as 10 teams and it's just grown from
there we now have 50 involved through
our alliance partner program whether it
be through the call center or their a
tag team whether they open their machine
shop many teams are alliance partners in
multiple ways so just getting to see
that from you know an initial call of ok
who is everyone to today you know a
trusted resource in the community in six
short months has just been unreal to be
a part of I think one of the other
reasons that we we created the compass
Alliance is the fact that we really
wanted to do big things and as a 31:32
that was one of one of our things that
we did we wanted to go bigger do more
yes but you reach a limit where you
can't do that just by yourself and so we
we gathered up these great teams who
wanted to do it who wanted to do more
and go bigger and do really cool things
and I think that really inspired us
because it's really cool to know that
there are people out there who really
want the - they have the initiative to
do that and we thought we should start
in the first community because that's
where we started and then we're just
going to go bigger and bigger as
yeah I think the other cool thing about
it is the benefit to the students so
normally you have your team's mentors
and they have a certain mentoring style
but because of the way this group has
come together a lot of the times like
our kids are being mentored by someone
from 125 or I might winter a kid from
citrus circuits like it just becomes
this even bigger community where we end
up mentoring each other's kids and they
get so much of a bigger perspective and
sometimes they work at different hours
sometimes they're not available because
they're already having other men your
mentor might be at work or wherever
they're at doing something else and you
need a mentor at that moment yes it's
opening up a whole new way for for for
kids to get the opportunity to design an
engineer the robots and also to work
with people around the world you get to
learn about what it's like for somebody
that lives in Turkey or Israel or South
America or wherever they're from the
week before our launch we're working on
the website literally 24/7 because we
are from around the world and so it was
just uh okay you know 125 Sark even this
time to this time and 503 is gonna head
it from here to here and then 31 32 is
gonna take over and it just became this
really fun like you hand off and you say
this is what I've done this is what he's
doing and we had Doc's going and I mean
yes that's what happens in the real
world these days right I worked a global
companies and that's what happens and so
it would be kids to experience it when
they're 15 16 17 they're gonna be so
well prepared when they get to the
workforce and they are doing shifts and
handing over to people in other time
zones because they've done it doesn't it
well such a good transition and then
also the the other teams that get to
join the compass Alliance they get to
say that we're dedicating our hours to
helping teams around the world so it
becomes another kind of like one of the
first connect or inspire okay so as we
talk a little bit about other countries
around the world I want to ask to get a
perspective from not only from having
lived in Australia you have lived Oh
as you were younger six then yeah yeah
and so and for the last ten years or so
for you in this era so the this the
world is moving towards globalization so
countries around the world are starting
to work more together politically
economically and there's a lot of
there's a lot of in the last two years
there's been a big push for this whole
nationalism movement in the United
States I'll focus on the US make sure
the u.s. is getting really great deals
and they're not getting screwed by China
and all this other kind of stuff so it's
just it's very interesting to see how
the world is working in this sense and
it's really good because we get so many
perspectives from people that are have
either started companies in Silicon
Valley or whatever whatever industries
they're in and it's good to maybe hear
from the perspectives of someone that's
younger and to thinks in maybe a
different a different generational way
so what do you guys think about
globalization so I think you know our
overall perspective in effect over time
for LA or 7 for everyone everywhere and
I think that extends beyond just stem I
think it extends to everything you know
the thing that binds us together is our
shared humanity yes and that is bigger
than any passport you can carry I think
we're probably a little bit biased we're
dual citizens now so we carry two
passports I think that really changes
your perspective on the world you know
through the first program we've worked
in schools that are 50% refugee and 97%
English as a second language and these
kids which is kids like I don't know how
to explain it besides they're just kids
and they're no different than kids here
and I mean they've had the roughest go
at life that's a
vegetable in Australia this is saying we
want to give everyone a fair go
these kids have not had a fair go in
life and so I think lots of things like
micronutrient deficiency that's
occurring for two billion people normal
and how does that not move you like as a
human mean how does it not move you to
here you go a fair girl yeah I like that
they all need a fair go and you know
absolutely there's bad stuff going on in
the world and we need to recognize that
and we need to fight injustice and that
comes in all sorts of forms and I think
I think in terms of fighting injustice
first does that and one of one of the
things where moments always said is
first is gonna stop a war yeah honestly
I can see it happening because at one of
the events that we had we had a Chinese
team and we had a Taiwanese team and I
don't I don't know if you know but
there's pretty big rivalry between the
two and they played on our alliance
together in fact a Chinese team picks
the Taiwanese team yeah and they they
didn't even talk about anything that was
going on in their countries they didn't
even mention it
they were just having a good time